hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in group 4 of the
Nicomachean ethics after a pretty
lengthy discussion of the specific
virtues and vices and what makes them so
with their their motives are how they
work eros level comes at last to discuss
something that isn't quite a virtue but
is connected with virtue and that is
what we're translating here as shame or
modesty the Greek term for this is
actually items and this is felt to be
quite important within Greek culture I'm
sure that somebody will probably bring
up it in the comments so I'm going to
preempt that right now that you know
ancient cultures Roisin cultures and
modern cultures they're dilt cultures
the reality of that is that it's much
more complicated and that a good part of
what we nowadays called guilt is
actually what we're translating here is
shame so it's helpful to put that
distinction when it's made to rigidly
assign and to think about what Aristotle
is actually saying here he suggests that
shame can be understood as a kind of
fear he doesn't follow this up but he
you know he's suggesting that it's a
kind of fear felt about one's social
image and also about one's self image
the word that he uses there it's a fear
of you no one's Doakes up the opinion
that people have or one's glory ones
reputation being in some way damaged he
and when I said this is not just felt in
relation to other people but also one
can feel this in relation to oneself as
well perhaps body but you know
incorporating the viewpoints of other
people are imagining what they have what
they would say why is this not a
virtuous disposition to feel this
Aristotle suggests first that well look
it's only an emotion so it's not really
a virtue dad said you could you could
probably say well what about courage
which has to do with confidence in fear
or temperance which has to do with you
know Soumya or desire for things or the
you know good temper which has to do
exactly with anger why not an emotion
the deeper reason is this there's
something fundamentally non-virtuous now
I'm not necessarily vicious but not
virtuous about feeling shame and we
should mention at this point that
although Aristotle doesn't doesn't call
this out and as such it's clear from the
kinds of examples that he uses
throughout his worse that we can feel
shame in two sorts of occasions one is
when we've actually screwed up we've
done something dumb or wrong or you know
counterproductive or socially
disapproved and you know we feel ashamed
because of that right the other is when
we imagine ourselves in that sort of
situation or we are considering doing
something and we hold back from it the
Greeks would say that it's your eye nose
your sense of shame that holds you back
from doing things like that you know for
example in our culture it's considered
rather rude
to to belch at a table right or to pick
ones nose or to you pick all sorts of
other things you know take a bath
incredible stick people but you don't
know we talkin and you know about people
not doing that not because they don't
want to because they feel embarrassed if
if they were to do that sort of thing
now I'm thinking of all sorts of other
funny examples of that but you can think
of examples on your arm now Aristotle
says here's here's why it's not a
virtuous emotion you don't feel it if
you're actually virtuous this is why
he's got this discussion distinguishing
between the young and the mature he says
it's only appropriate to young people as
a matter of fact it's a good thing for a
young person had a sense of shame why
because he says they live by passions
their rationality is not fully developed
they're not really following you know
the guidelines that they have except you
know the you know when when it's become
a bitch'll most of the time they're
driven by their desires and their
emotions you know what it was like to be
young right
so they do a lot of dumb stuff they make
mistakes and if you're like me and you
think back to your adolescence you know
your teen years and and your 20s you
probably have a whole host of examples
that you could bring up things that you
actually you know do feel ashamed about
or things that you almost did that
you're really glad you didn't because
some sort of sense of shame he'll be
back so like we're feeling this feeling
neither if you screw it up get you back
on track right you break somebody's
fence down you not only fix the fence
you actually you know apologize to them
and you exhibit a sense of shame and
apologizing it also can keep you on
track so that that's quite important
Arizona says that for mature people
feeling shame is actually a sign of
something going wrong it's a sign of
lacking virtue this doesn't mean that
they're necessarily
yes or even uncontrolled they cravaack
it could be that they are the self
controlled person who still wants to do
things that they know are not good for
them are good for other people who wants
to do actions that would be base that
would be ignoble right that would be
shameful so if you're feeling shame it's
a sign of a lack of virtue
what about virtuous people want to let
you know air is low status and this is
being a little bit optimistic at this
point because remember virtue does not
automatically guarantee moral success
just guarantees that it's probably going
to be that way because there's a
habitual disposition but the virtuous
person can't still screw up the use of
the virtuous person feels shame only by
hypothesis they say to themselves well
yeah if I were to do the sort of things
that those people over there do I
wouldn't in fact feel ashamed at doing
those I'm not I'm not not doing those
things motivated by a sense of shame I'm
not doing them because they conflict
with actually doing the right thing over
here that I want to do because I'm
virtuous you know that's what it means
to be virtuous but if I wants to do that
thing I would feel bad about it and I
would you know rightly feel bad about it
so that's that's my hypothesis as he's
saying it's something that it's it can
be imagined but it's not an active
temptation let alone a reality that they
have to face Aristotle does say that we
are dealing with something that is a
mean condition when we're talking about
shame you can feel too much of it so
let's say you're not virtuous and you're
constantly worried about embarrassing
yourself you're bashful
as a result you're you know you don't
open your mouth up because you're afraid
that what you say is going to be wrong
and people are going to laugh at you
Arizona would say well they have to say
that's a problem it's not quite advice
but it is an access right likewise one
that he's much more concerned about
shamelessness
literally in in the Greek a nice Oneonta
that's a defect the person who lacks a
sense of shame if they're not virtuous
will do all sorts of things they will
get into all sorts of trouble nothing
will hold them back they won't care
about their reputation or what other
people think of them they probably won't
care about how they look at themselves
in the mirror the next day they're just
gonna do what they're gonna do now you
know is there a difference then between
the virtuous person who doesn't feel
shame and this other person yeah because
this other person does shameful things
right they are not a virtuous person so
being virtuous would preclude the
defective of shamelessness remember too
that shamelessness is among those things
that Aristotle said us are by their very
nature path and there can be no
appropriate mean - there isn't a mean
there is no right amount of
shamelessness right there is a right
amount of shame there is no right amount
of shamelessness that's we have one
extreme so this is why shame is a very
important moral phenomena but it's not
quite a virtue so it's been sometimes
called the quasi virtue I would just
prefer the term not a virtue it is
however connected as we can see with
virtue and with the good luck